Speaker 1: All right. Let's review some
of the coverage, I guess we would call it,
including on FOX News of the firing of Tucker
Carlson. Some of this stuff is really funny.
Some of it's kind of sad. Some of it's, you
know, a little bit of both are somewhere in
between. I'm going to start with a clip of Harris
Faulkner. Harris Faulkner has increasingly been
one of the more notable kind of partizan hacks on
Fox News, I think is the term that I would use in
a lot of different ways. She devoted 35 seconds
to telling us that Tucker Carlson is no longer
going to be at Fox News. She falsely said that
Tucker and Fox agreed to go their separate ways.
What's funny about that term is like, in a sense,
any time someone's fired, the parties have agreed
that they won't work there anymore in the sense
that the person who's fired doesn't really have
a choice. Like if they leave and they don't show
back up. So in that sense, they've agreed. But the
suggestion that this was mutual is, of course,
wrong. The funniest part of this clip, though,
is the delivery. It's almost like it's a eulogy
at a funeral. But kind of even even weirder, she's
really struggling through this. Let's take a look.
Speaker 3: We have some news from within our
Fox family. Fox News media and Tucker
Carlson have mutually agreed to part ways.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And again, it's not
really mutual in so far as when you're
fired. You kind of have to accept it.
Speaker 3: Tucker's last show was
this past Friday.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Speaker 3: And starting tonight, Fox News
Tonight will air live at 8 p.m. Eastern.
It will be an interim show with rotating Fox
News personalities until a new host is named.
We want to thank Tucker Carlson for his time.
Speaker 1: She's acting like this is going
to be the naming of a new pope. You know, I
mean, and but but, you know, I'm not Catholic,
so it's not like I even really glorify the naming
of a new pope. But when you consider the pomp and
circumstance around it, she's acting like at some
point two or, you know, the next the next Dalai
Lama is going to be selected as host.
Speaker 3: And prior to that
as a long term contributor.
Speaker 1: Wow. So really, only 31 seconds
and then 4 seconds of silence there. The funniest
part is when she said that it was mutual for sure.
There was really nothing mutual about it. Then
we go to Charlie Kirk. Charlie Kirk, one of the
most I mean, I would say prominent and powerful
right wing voices when it comes to indoctrinating
college and recently college age people, I
think is a fair a praise of sorts of Charlie
Kirk. He is talking about Tucker as if Tucker
died almost. It's like he just got fired. He'll
do his propaganda elsewhere. But Charlie Kirk also
sounds like he's eulogizing Tucker Carlson here.
Some tech issues here, too.
Speaker 2: Tucker Carlson
really made the right. That is one thing I will
agree with the view on. He was more powerful
than anybody else since the death of Rush
Limbaugh in reshaping the right, in moving.
The Overton Window in pushing forward. Positive
narratives in challenging Operation Mockingbird
and. I'd say this is somebody who knows Tucker
very well. He did not care about the backlash.
Speaker 1: Right. And he is still alive. I know.
You might think. Wow. So Tucker died. I guess
Tucker is alive. He's just been fired. And he will
I am sure. I am certain. I'm confident he will
continue doing all of those things that Charlie
talked about just on a different network. And then
the third reaction to this and this I love this
is a message I can really get behind. The third
reaction has been stop watching Fox News. We need
listen, they fired Bongino now. They fired Tucker.
And Jesse WATTERS is on paternity leave, which I
guess when Pete booted Judge took paternity leave,
it was bad. But Jesse WATTERS can take paternity
leave. It's all very strange. But the message that
they've been coming up with is it's time to
not watch Fox News anymore. That is a message
I can get behind Here is propaganda.
Steve Bannon suggesting that approach.
Speaker 4: Which I've said, hey, the reason to
watch Fox, you got Maria in the morning. You've
got you've got Jesse, right. He's going
there. But Tucker is really the reason to
watch Fox with this. I don't know why anybody
needs to watch anything on the Murdoch empire,
because Tucker was the mainstay of the the
populous voice over at Fox, and it's just
a blockbuster news. Tucker's announced he's
leaving and not just at the last show was.
Speaker 1: Tucker didn't really announce that
he's leaving like even that. That's also not
true. Tucker hasn't. And Tucker on Friday thought
he would be back. Yesterday, Tucker was fired.
He's announced that he's leaving, but he night.
Speaker 4: So tonight they're going to replace
him with, I don't know, Fox News tonight or
something, but no, Tucker Carlson at Fox News. It
looks like no Tucker Carlson and Fox Nation, the
streaming service will get more details of that.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he's been fired. Okay. So he
announced that he's leaving. Listen, the not
watching Fox, I mean that Steve Bannon is known
for. Political maneuvering that includes the use
of so-called chaos agents. In fact, there's now
a report and I'm not saying that this is actually
completely accurate. It's a report, and I haven't
looked at it yet, but there's a report that
Bannon has been encouraging Bobby Kennedy Jr to
run against Biden, not because Bannon likes Bobby
Kennedy Jr, but as a, quote, chaos agent. A really
great chaos agent type move would be for the right
to come out with a campaign against fox news. That
would be an absolute and total delight. So I'm
behind that. Stop watching fox news the way steve
Bannon says that was the reaction from some on
air people. Let's now look at the reaction at Fox
News to Tucker's firing from staffers. Pure joy.